so this would have been the perfect
Mother's Day movie all right I was
actually saying I wish we had opened it
on Mother's Day weekend and just like
messed everybody
oh it's funny I'm watching the movie and
feeling all these feelings for mother
like I'm I'm feeling sympathetic
I'm feeling emotional about her and
she's a robot and is she feeling that
about you but that's the question is the
question right that is the question
that's what grant talks about about AI I
think I never really thought about
artificial intelligence I'm not a huge
sci-fi fan in general but this script
was so thought-provoking and there's so
much heart within it that I was
completely drawn to it but one of the
things that he talked about was AI and
the idea of developing a AI and how
they're not programmed we don't program
them we they're built and then they have
their experiences but they're so
exponentially smarter mm-hmm and they
learn so much quicker but do they
empathize do they have the ability to
empathize we don't know that we don't
know you don't know you don't know when
they started having experiences with
human beings that hopefully have empathy
how they will react and walk around in
the world have you ever watched those
like Boston Dynamics videos of them
testing out a robot No so these the one
just doing backflips and yeah yeah
grandma talks about them all the time
and they kick it like they kick over
this robot and you know it's just a
thing they made but you feel bad well
that's boring in the anyway have you
ever felt a connection to an inanimate
object like an emotional connection to
an inanimate object that you know is
just ridiculous thing that's also
projection right project what we
experienced and that is our reality so
we think that everyone is has that
reality and then you evolve and grow and
have experience and realize oh people
realities are different yeah yeah so but
absolutely we do that isn't there like
when you're in grade school now they
have like these little animals that you
take care of and you you know they're
not real right and that you have to take
care of them in water and sure yeah and
then of course you're you you you give
them so much love you you would think
that they they're receiving that I know
yeah your scenes together they're all
really tight two handers and with really
like almost claustrophobic scenarios
you're very close yeah what did you
learn from each other being in that
spacecraft because this is all just the
two of you thought was good to brush
your teeth you you know when you're
working intimately like that it's it's
interesting because this I don't know
any other business where you meet
someone and then maybe then very next
day you're like either you can be in
each other's arms like crying or you
know you're forced quickly to be really
intimate and to know each other yeah and
to trust each other
and it's you know it's it's um and and
it can be it's great when it works and
other times you know it's very
vulnerable right there's a bit of a
parallel here you're like between 1820
when you're kind of getting your break
in you're 21 now so working together did
she give you any advice or were you like
just like so literally there were scenes
when we were doing the two handles where
I would find myself forgetting that I
was acting and I was like okay yeah I
mean I need to yeah it's just so
fascinating watching you work and
nervously she's fantastic people know
this is a known fact um so yeah I was by
the way I mental know it's 16 not know
you were young ago yeah I was in Buffy
the Vampire Slayer the movie I thought
yours where you got your six just had my
driver's license that's so good